what's that breasts my name's para de
pie welcome back to some more how lass
I know ah Oh better run man [ __ ] out
don't be the sewing guy and I hate him
I'll be back here oh my gosh Ness what
am i hello how how is these cuts a sweet
sweet send the sweets it's cray-cray Wow
my forehead is you couldn't just keep
perhaps couldn't just play along
now
no it's my boyfriend my boyfriend he's
gonna kill you I'll work on it
after he goes do a little dance do a
little dance that went better than
expected girl that went better than
expected
except not really what's our play now oh
all right I'm dead this is that big ass
[ __ ]
no big daddy's back he's not gonna come
in I can't I can't
hi I miss you don't pull my underwear
I guess they missed me too huh
cupcake Marco hello easy does it no need
to run in scarran Oh God
exit over there that means death trap
over there thank you game come on
swallow go home I hear him
oh [ __ ] that stick out where did he go
I'm a table iswe the spawn a table I am
a proper [ __ ] table too
now one of those I care tables what is
he doing
Oh God is fine oh [ __ ] I think you heard
me
this is great footage him this might end
up in the calendar great ass is 2014
they will make a great January cover
actually oh [ __ ] I see
easy easy don't don't you ever say the
fat man isn't gay I will away shut up
got a squeeze it through early [ __ ] -
oh god okay I really
that makes sense the toilet can't talk
oh god it's us - oh we've been here yeah
don't be afraid you do thank you I feel
special you know what yeah we definitely
played hurt
you go down that hole oh my god that's
okay that's it is kind of cool
hey what's going on in here Oh a
surprise egg
oh yeah I remember him
alright well I guess we go here then
come on this [ __ ] again if you listen
that [ __ ] is he coming a wife
anyone was a fire can't stand that
[ __ ] guy okay okay all right coast is
clear
heck heck yes babe wash your hands yeah
that's the biggest problem here
not enough sanitation that's why people
go crazy that's why they call it sanity
sanitarium
I think batteries but the my learnings
gone you can't go on I guess I should
change the lyrics when the flashlights
on and you can't go on no wait
you're trying oh well this place it's my
favorite place in there was
I take that back you know what I'm gonna
go on the limb here and say I'll take
that [ __ ] back this is so much fun
wow this is like a exercise I love it
just [ __ ] love it so much
nay oh what's up finally I can take this
this game is like [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
I gotcha legs why would I go back in I'm
out I'm afraid I'm afraid add it's not
really someone whispering out there it's
probably just a man
all right what do we got over here yes
you know what I would like to hoping we
go down that creepy hellhole well those
are my favorite type of holes all right
can we go through Oh
nicely yes very acrobatic ten points to
me don't get the camera wait bro
I would kind of suck at all the files
got corrupted or some [ __ ]
this is definitely a crap
someone calling RAL ow
toasty you're gonna have to do something
about that we can go here I didn't see
that I thought that was where we came
from fun fun fun fun lookin forward to
the weekend this place is so big
all right down here then this is very
welcoming
allow
you do it in oh come on say
that is so hello
Shetty that is nice don't look kids
oops then I mean to be a party pooper
oh god this [ __ ] game can I do I wish
I could do something with this cassette
is there everywhere I think they're
pretty pissed now
but I think they're pretty pissed anyway
to be honest
okay here we are no electricity anymore
he got it on anyway
it's the time at the [ __ ] how does it
make sense
how did that happen you see down there
cuz I don't want to go down there if
he's down there is he [ __ ] with me
what hello where did he go
way yeah ain't nobody now Oh God [ __ ]
hell as soon as I saw saving I'm like
nope oh god don't chase me bro don't
chase you know what you know what you
know what you're not welcome [ __ ] why
don't you ever say um what in my butt
what what Emma but but what I'm about
I'm a girl here girl you're still not
welcome [ __ ]
it really likes me I think he has a
crush on me it's not good
better keep him out all right
great times out of this place don't you
ever [ __ ] tiny little duck it's dancing
this is my therapy I need some [ __ ] Oh
God ghosts now that's great times ghosts
see you later
just trying to be positive that's my
that's my thing to get through this [ __ ]
so many the works in this place like
they [ __ ] invented the door to see
okay what's your short in fact probably
more fat than joy and on that - huh what
about here
not very good
all right a little swim has never killed
anyone
hello
Oh
oh there we go I thank God I don't want
to stay in here
that's good I did it
boy that was not good
[ __ ] this place so much this is such a
nightmare we can't go there
we can't go into here like a dog like a
dog it down
who dropped you man
Oh what's it fun though uh would you do
it again well let's try it ourself thing
that's what my mom said you don't know
if you don't try
it's a great woman let's close the door
she didn't say anything about going
where it's better want to close it make
me feel safer
this is cool like a tie pretty epic
hello
no one okay it's not like anyone ever
answer what no that [ __ ]
all right I'm I ain't afraid of those
okay I ain't afraid a little bad breath
you know I'm saying I've been through
worse
not yet not scared I'm badass and that's
game now you're supposed to go opera
sir probably haven't done a ladder scare
those are really [ __ ] hard
all right let's try this thing that
looks fun
and you blow my whistle baby whistle
baby yo oh hello come on we didn't come
this far where are we now it was broken
like a 10-million ribs brass birch of
butter elbows I'm sorry to interfere but
we have to end this episode here please
leave like if you're watching and I'll
see you tomorrow love you